hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zum neuen Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut ich bin heute
hier in Zeitz beim Dealer Shopping
Center direkt mal ein bisschen Werbung
machen beim Daniel na alles fit Grüße ja
daniel hat mich auf jeden Fall mal
eingeladen ich hatte das schon länger
vorher mal vorbei zu schauen wir uns
damals kennengelernt bei den
returmprofis als ich da so ein paar
Retouren entfernen ausgepackt habe und
er meinte mal Alex du musst doch mal bei
mir vorbeikommen und das hat jetzt ganz
gut gepasst und heute bin ich hier ihr
sieht man ein paar kurze Ausschnitte du
verkaufst hier alles mögliche Retouren
halt alles ne wir sind das was man der
Sendung auch sind wir verkaufen wirklich
ausschließlich Retouren vom Fernsehen
lassen wir weg wir verkaufen hier im
Laden in Zeitz online ein bisschen und
haben verschiedene Händler
deutschlandweit wo wir die Aufbereitung
machen und die Ware verkaufen ja ich
habe mir schon einiges angeguckt für
mich selber sehr interessant daher hat
mich so ein bisschen rumgeführt wie
immer gesagt wir müssen auch irgendwie
was cooles machen und wir haben uns
jetzt folgendes überlegt hinter uns ist
eine riesen Retouren Palette wenn er
gerade wieder fleißig dabei ein paar
Retouren auszupacken der Plan ist jetzt
folgender wir machen so eine kleine
Challenge willst du das erklären im
Endeffekt kann man sich überlegt wir
machen einen battle war der Retouren
Profis beide nennen wir uns jetzt
einfach noch mal so
aber wir haben gesagt wir schätzen
einmal jeder den Inhalt dieser Palette
und ja das kriegt er sie dass sie frei
eines Kartons Entschuldigung also ich
erkläre es noch mal für Youtube hier
sind sechs Kartons drauf und in allen
Kartons sind halt verschiedene Retouren
drin jeder Karton hat einen Wert wir
öffnen die und schauen was drin ist dann
sagen wir z.B Karton 1 ich schätze
Gesamtwert ist 600 € Daniel sagt
Gesamtwert ist 800 €. dann schauen wir
nach was der Gesamtwert ist der Punkt
geht dann entweder an Daniel oder an
mich wer dann von den sechs Punkten die
meisten einfährt kriegt dann entweder
die ganze Palette wenn ich gewinne weil
das ist ja gerade noch deine Palette und
wenn nicht dann helfe ich Dir einmal bei
beim online verkauft ein Live-Shopping
mit uns wird eingekleidet im Dealer
Modus und dann ja kannst du mal zeigen
was du vor der Kamera als Verkäufer dann
noch okay und ich würde sagen let's go
weißt du ungefähr was wir zu schätzen
was der Gesamtwert von der ganzen
Palette also UVP kannst du nicht nee
also das sind posten die sind im Prinzip
nur pro Kategorie ja meistens ist in
eine Kategorie aber 10 oder 12 Paletten
da habe ich werte und bei dem Rest
müssen wir nicht was drin ist okay für
mich komplett jetzt Überraschung alles
klar nice es mache ich doch gerne machen
wir mal auf
okay Leute wir haben jetzt hier die
erste Box von der Palette
mal hinterher noch wissen welche welche
war bin mal gespannt weil für mich ist
es ja auch wichtig muss ich erst das
Zeug legen damit das alles in mein neues
Lager kommt also schaut mal rein
also wir sind zwei Gläser drin
das Problem ist ich habe von so Gläsern
und so Deko eigentlich gar keine Ahnung
oder von so Tisch Sachen das Problem ist
selbst ich als 22 Jahre handelserfahrung
ist schwierig naja ihr kennt das Ding
kann alles kostenlos
ein Euro
ja schätz mal 1 €, das finde ich sehr
gut bis jetzt dann noch ein bisschen
mehr okay wir halten fest was ist denn
das hier
Crystal ist ja auch ein Glas Crystal
darkees heißt das ach so Rotweingläser
ich habe auch bei mir noch ganz viele so
Rotweingläser rumfliegen die muss ich
auch alle doch loswerden ja wir gehen
aber eigentlich immer gut ne hier ist
der Klassiker bestimmt wenn hier das ist
ein Vierer Set oh hier sind bestimmt das
war zum Glück kein Glas
drei Gläser kriegt man noch verkauft
natürlich müsste den Preis von 4 wir
Deckel
machen
ich würde sagen das sind ja Gläser
müssen wir die alle einzeln angucken
geil geil
Weihnachten
kostet 44,99
original 100 € draußen also du hast
schon glaube ich ein leichten Vorteil
gegenüber würde ich jetzt nicht sagen
okay pass auf lass das so wir schätzen
jetzt direkt
mal nur es sind sechs Gläser wieder mal
wahrscheinlich nur fünf guck mal hier
immer noch Messer und Gabel so ja
schätze mal kannst du vielleicht
anfangen geht das wir schätzen den UVP
ne das muss genau ja
wir haben Glück Gott sei Dank eine Liste
wo man es wirklich nach kontrollieren
können ich sag mal alleine hier locker
flockig
780 €, also Daniel sagt 780 boah
ich hätte also ich hätte sogar
eigentlich fast mehr gesagt also UVP ist
ja immer ne ziemlich dann sage ich
einfach mal 790 das ist natürlich
hier
[Musik]
denkst du das hier drin ja sieht nach
Deko aus ne sowas spannend spannend aber
hier sind auch noch andere Sachen drin
ne ne
dasselbe sein oder ähnliches aber das
jetzt irgend
Trikot und Lampen aus okay noch ein
Lampenschirm das ist ein Mülleimer da
unten oder auch ein Lampenschirm aber
Lampenschirme könnte man ja auch als
Mülleimer verwenden
genau
[Musik]
wegschmeißen nein wir verkaufen das noch
mit dem kleinen Defekt dafür halt für
weniger Geld mega also der passt auch
richtig gut in meine Wohnung zum
Beispiel ja denke ich auch oder also das
ist jetzt auf jeden Fall weniger wert
grande kunstdrucker
kannst du einmal das
Mikrofone zu tun
wir schätzen direkt wieder rein ich
fange an UVP 370 370sc 34 Kissen keine
Ahnung was für ein Lampenschirm kostet
ne ja das Problem ist die können
wirklich von diskosten jetzt machst du
so einen ähnlichen move wie du darfst
380 so also hier haben wir jetzt Alex
370 Daniel 380 wir halten fest Leute am
Ende wandern alle Boxen entweder zu mir
oder halt nicht wir machen jetzt hier
mal weiter ja
Spielzeuge was sind denn so die Sachen
die du am meisten hier hast ja schon
Deko in living also alles was so im
Bereich
Möbel oder sowas geht auch immer mehr
was hier so passiert also auch gerne mal
Spielzeug wie man sieht ey das finde ich
geil mega das ist ja wie Autorennen für
Kinder nur auf dem Wasser genau
ganz oder nicht
waren alles einmal gecheckt ja ne
digital
Partyspiel ab 18 Jahren Alter nice
aber ich dachte das war das nicht mehr
Baby gespielt hat Palette ja das ist ja
für Baby Boss ne also wie ist das denn
ach so ja gut die können das schon
spielen und hier ist eine Creme oder nee
was ist das nee Kleber boah das wird ja
auch wieder schwierig ey uns ist es halt
irgendwie Weihnachten jeden Tag ne du
willst nicht was drin ist am Ende hast
du dann immer hier irgendein schönes
Sachen
badewindeln
erinnert
ich weiß nicht was ich da schätzen soll
anfangen fast 30 Artikel ich sage immer
770 weil ich finde auch genau UVP sagen
wir mal hier dieses Jetski Dingen das
kostet doch bestimmt neu 65 € finde
ich mal gespannt 80 € diesmal hier ich
habe es drauf
das ist natürlich sportlich ne für so
ein Ding darf ich jetzt mein Geburt noch
mal erhöhen nee was habe ich gesagt 640
oder sagt ja irgendwie so so dann haben
wir auch schon die dritte so Leute
weiter geht's glaube ich bin eigentlich
ganz gut im Rennen würde ich sagen
schauen wir mal was wir jetzt hier noch
so haben Fahne das geht wieder in
Richtung Küche aber die sind richtig
teuer ne also so nur 50 € oder 40
€, ja ja
noch spannender oder irgendwelche
Aufbewahrungsbox für die Küche eine
Backform von Dr Oetker also auch Marke
wieder mal dabei das ist gut also du
hast ja gesagt du hast hier viel auch so
Küchensachen habt ihr schon mal so
Teller gefunden so geisteskrank teuer
sind also es gibt ja so richtige Luxus
Teller die 1000 € kosten richtig kann
ich dir sogar zeigen nachher wir haben
vorne eine Toilette da haben wir einen
Teller seit 84 Teile kostet 1189 €
draußen weiß gold und das habt ihr durch
Zufall gefunden
also das ist der angegebene UVP jetzt
machen wir uns nichts vor das wird
natürlich draußen immer anders gehandelt
aber ja so sollte es mal rausgehen
ah da weiß ich ja jetzt schon dass die
88 € kostet
10 echt ja dann hast du so eine 8 oder 9
schätze ich und die das sind auch ganz
gefragte Handschuhe die sind auch teuer
ja danke das ist super und warte mal da
ich also selbstbewusst bin und davon
ausgehe dass ich eh Gewinne lasse ich
die mal hier drin okay ich schätze
einfach mal 534 €. okay hier denke ich
dass du weit runter legst ich sag eine
820 okay Leute wir haben jetzt schon mal
die vier Paletten da hinten hingestellt
das ist jetzt die fünfte die wir noch
aufmachen werden und schätzen werden die
sechste werden mir zulassen einfach
damit kein Unentschieden geben kann weil
das wäre ja auch doof Teller über Teller
Leser Kartons und man muss ja auch sagen
alles was Du hier hast wird irgendwo mal
wieder zusammengebaut und dann
eingepackt und so ne also ja das landet
halt auch viele Markt weil alles macht
doch nicht schicken weil gerade Cluster
wissen dann hast du nur wieder Stress
deswegen das Verkaufen am meisten mag
aber das sind ja schon wieder hier haben
wir jetzt auch wieder Gläser und so hey
ich habe keinen Plan man so eine Salah
ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben eine
Salatschüssel gekauft nee ich weiß wie
die aussieht aber ich habe ihn ja komm
zeig mal einmal muss ja auch wieder
anfangen mit Schätzen du kannst ja schon
mal anfangen ja ich sag mal so die 780
würde ich mit mir immer egal
jetzt habe ich mein Tipp schon abgegeben
also ich würde auch sagen boah das ist
bestimmt wieder was hast du gesagt 780
780 mein Tipp jetzt hier pass auf dann
mache ich jetzt das ein bisschen eklig
sagt 780 und 1 Cent
hör auf jetzt ist die Frage entscheidet
ihr ein verdammtes Cent oder nicht okay
und das ist jetzt noch zu hier die der
letzte okay Leute wir haben jetzt Olivia
hinter der Kamera die ich die ganzen
Zahlen schon besorgt hat von den
einzelnen Boxen die sind ja alle halt
auch so durchnummeriert und so deswegen
würde ich sagen wir machen jetzt die
Auflösung bin echt gespannt ob der eine
Cent den du jetzt mehr getippt hast am
Ende entscheidend ist und ich hier meine
schöne Palette retour Ware verloren habe
oder ob du zum live kommst schön in
schwarze kleidet und vor der Kamera
richtig wenn ich jetzt auch nicht
schlimm würde ich sagen wir starten mal
mit Karton eins wo liegt der
97 Euro tut mir leid so viel oh okay 1:0
für Daniel 127 50 liegt noch weit
daneben ne ich mach mal einen Kreis das
kann doch nicht so viel kosten er war
doch na ja gut egal 10 Scheiße wir
machen weiter mit dem zweiten Karton wo
liegt der
664,90 € hä das geht gut los aber ich
sag mal so wir sind beide Fußballfans
warte mal kurz du hast dich hier
verguckt das war meiner hast du mich
okay ich wollte schon sagen das kann
doch nicht sein läuft das immer so bei
dir hier ab oder was siehst du den
Kunden ab
so Punkt 1:1 okay das ist schon mal gut
ich dachte schon ich liege schon zwei
nach hinten okay dann haben wir den
Karton 3 was haben wir da
[Musik]
zwei eins zwei eins okay Karton 4 aber
warte mal ganz kurz ich würde schon
sagen das ist ja alles wir liegen ja so
oft so krass drunter das heißt ich bin
mir sicher hier hast du jetzt wieder
geworden
echt Angst habe vor der letzten hast du
mehr geworden und wenn ich die
Entwicklung so richtig deute wie hier
das war wirklich weit runterladen immer
könntest du mit dem einzelnen doch
wirklich den Sieg eingefahren habe okay
was kostet Karton 4
guck mal einfach doppelt so viel wie ich
getippt habe was sind daran so teuer
gewesen
und jetzt haben wir noch den letzten
Karton 5 hier vorne ich habe gesagt ja 1
Cent mehr sag einfach direkt
okay geil aber gemacht
geil ich wünsche dir viel Spaß also so
viel Zeugs hatte ich noch nie hier so
Deko und bums aber
dann komme ich nachher nicht rein warum
da kommst Du gerade reingehen ja Nein
okay ja Leute vielen Dank fürs zuschauen
danke für die Einladung hat auf jeden
Fall Spaß gemacht
ja check mal den Daniel ab und seinen
ganzen Laden hier wenn er Bock habt oder
aus der Nähe kommt danke fürs zuschauen
Leute Däumchen nach oben wenn nice
abonniert den Kanal auch immer ganz
wichtig Ciao macht's gut Ciao
lieber kriegst du gleich gratis mit dazu
da bin ich hier endlich los ist super
Möglichkeit ist keine Retoure ohne
Gewährleistung
[Musik]